hit the nail on the knob knobs are great
tuned guys
we love knobs Joey the kid just doesn't
know this [ __ ] he's not paid to know
this [ __ ] who is texting me hey guys I'm
a br welcome to Abby's kitchen today
we're having a little movie night and
we're going to be talking a little bit
about the new hot food documentary on
Netflix what the help so if you haven't
yet seen it count your lucky stars but
I'm going to give you a little overview
basically the film follows the filmmaker
Kip Anderson as he goes undercover to
try to find out all the dangers of a
meat-based diet now listen guys I love
my vegan friends I am NOT against this
film because it's promoting a
plant-based diet I'm against this film
because of the misinformation and the
manipulations cheap shots that they're
willing to take to make their point so
let's do a little movie night now mic
music just one serving of deli meats
daily increases your risk of colorectal
cancer by 18 percent I had no idea that
what we ate affected cancer rate and I
never felt like I'd eaten a lot of
processed meats until I realized that
possibly hot dogs bacon sausage salami
ham pepperoni cold cuts and deli slices
babe I'm sorry if you didn't realize
that bacon was considered a processed
meat what else would have been a
processed meat I don't understand
bacon hot dogs baloney and he's confused
and surprised that this is considered
under the blanket of processed foods
this guy's not really the smartest
person puli not the kind of person I
want to be taking nutrition advice from
just saying alright kids well let's just
take a little little step back here and
let's meet our friend kid so if you've
seen his last documentary cowspiracy
you'll know that even though he presents
himself like he's just coming into
veganism right now and exploring this
this new territory he's been a vegan for
quite a while I mean this is nothing new
this is not his first rodeo
and so I guess we know that both of the
directors have quite a lot of biases
going in and that becomes incredibly
evident when you see the kinds of vegan
doctors that they choose to feature in
the film
now listen Kip I totally get it it's
really hard to go into a filmmaking
opportunity without some kind of
preconceived notion about what you want
to talk about or your specific angle but
just come up say it
don't pretend like you're going on this
fact-finding mission when you've clearly
already found all the facts that you
want to find I mean just be honest
so issue number one keep shitty
journalism skills the guy's got no game
oh hi I was calling because I was
wondering why you all recommend people
the processed meat on your website which
the World Health Organization is
classified as a group 1 carcinogen which
is in the same class of tobacco smoking
asbestos and plutonium this would be
like a lung association having a how to
roll your own cigarette section on their
website ok
kind of the same thing not the same
thing he wasn't able to answer my
questions and said so oh yeah are you
really not surprised I mean you called a
1-800 number and spoke to probably like
an intern he's not paid to know be a
massive vast body of research out there
on that topic I mean that'll be like we
in the grocery store and asking the bag
boy how profitable that location is ok
so moving on clearly Kip does not
improve his journalism game because he
does it again later on in the film let's
take a look at your website we know this
heart healthy recipes and we're kind of
bewildered by why there's a bunch of
recipes on the whole section on beef
beef recipes there's also a section on
Ed recipes when there's such a strong
link between beef red meat and heart
disease
I I honestly don't know because I don't
get that again that's not what I do
another organization that that wasn't
able to answer my questions but he said
that he'd had someone get in touch
shortly I mean obviously Kip again you
seem to interpret this is not what I do
in - oh I'm hiding something the guy
does not know these things so he can't
give you the information why would he
know these things it's just not his job
there's no my god listen Kip you really
think that the security guard is going
to have memorized all the peer-reviewed
journals out there for the company that
he represents it's still his job the
flesh sure that I would eliminate from
the American diet would be post it would
be perky and chicken with brilliant
advertising campaigns convinced people
to always like me that's healthier okay
Kip so if you skipped out on journalism
school which I assume that you did let
me do a little recap for you some of the
hallmarks of good journalism is that
you're getting on both sides of the coin
that you're interviewing people with
different perspectives and clearly
you're taking advantage fat here in what
the health because almost like a
majority of the doctors that you've
interviewed here are vegan and they
support a plant-based diet in a variety
of money-making ways so it seems like
you are not okay with this but somehow
you're okay with this you might want to
get your priorities straight there Kip
issue number two is dramatics so this
film is a huge fan of dark scary rooms
and vivid imagery
and big crazy words that they used for
male paranoia about food a ham pepperoni
cold cuts and deli slices basically
everything I grew up eating the World
Health Organization classifies process
meet as a group 1 carcinogen the same
group as cigarettes asbestos and
plutonium can classifies red meat as a
group 2 carcinogen was this like I had
essentially been smoking my entire
childhood Oh
if processed meats are labeled the same
as cigarettes how is it even legal for
kids to be eating this way
father some scary imagery Kip honestly
if I were a parent I would be really
freaked out about it too but I think
you've really misunderstood the research
here so when the who released the report
linking process needs to cancer and
categorizing process needs in the same
category as asbestos and tobacco they
were doing so with the understanding
that the category represented the
strength of the research and not
necessarily the risk these
classifications didn't really give us
any understanding of how much process
meats you would need to consume in order
to increase your risk of cancer or even
how much it would increase your risk the
classifications are being put into these
categories meant that the strength of
the research linking process needs to
cancer was similar to the strength of
the research linking tobacco to cancer
so this is not an attempt to make these
things the same thing because they're
not the same thing so let me reiterate
that one more time the only things that
are similar between tobacco and
processed meat so to come to cancer is
the strength of that research as well as
the fact that of course there was some
correlation and hip correlation does not
equal causation that's just basic
understanding of research director
general have a lot of other products
associated with it not least of which is
class I mean they actually have laws
limiting how much puffs you can actually
have in an open still so I believe it's
like 750,000 plus those four simply
doesn't mean you wouldn't want too much
positive you should pass people not
reject in fact to get think of cheese is
kind of coagulate cow pulse if you were
when I was always told that we need milk
first
I mean dad is the guy getting paid per
puff like obviously we don't like the
word pus so they're just going to shove
it in there and shove it down your
throat as many times in association with
dairy milk because that's going to turn
you off the [ __ ] wallet when we need
these kind of getting back to the
tossing with
what does that even mean honestly dead
meat bacterial toxins it just like a
bunch of really scary words strung
together in an effort to scare you and
it's scary man I'm scared
there's chicken there it's a question of
whether you want to be shot or all the
flesh food alike so scary
I mean who says that does he actually go
at home and think about the the
parallels between different ways of
dying and consuming different kinds of
animal proteins that should stop I never
really thought about eggs much I just
thought of them as a standard part of a
healthy diet but then I found a study
suggesting that eating just one egg a
day to be as bad as smoking 5 cigarettes
per day for life expectancy oh my god
where does he wear that people get their
medical degrees I think it needs to go
back to school and take that one
nutrition course all over again because
there is a lot going on in an egg yolk
egg yolks have protein healthy fats
calcium iron phosphorus selenium fully
vitamins b12 vitamin D vitamin A and
carotenoids I mean there's a lot going
on in that little yo still think it's
crap
no yo wrong issue number three the use
of personal testimonials as research so
for us a film we've run into a variety
of very selected individuals who are
suffering from a wide range of chronic
diseases like heart disease type 2
diabetes and osteoporosis which are
really big serious problems the problem
is this film insinuates that the reason
these people have chronic disease is
because they'd be consuming meat all
their lives when the reality is we know
that nutrition is just one factor
contributing to chronic disease risk my
name is Michael of dollars Michael and
Georgia and unfortunately I was
diagnosed about 10 years ago with
diabetes and eight years ago I had two
stents put in I don't know where to go I
don't know what to do you just like out
of options and you don't know what to do
taking medicine unison to this doctor
and the cardiologist says
take this and in the inner core
knowledge it says take that mean you're
doing practitioner doctor says you don't
know what's going on here and it's a
real it's a real challenging thing and
it's something that you don't want to
get it you just don't want to get
government in yeah that's Michael and
Michael's got diabetes and sounds like
heart disease he's had a few stents put
in and she's taking all these
medications and insulin and you know
it's overwhelming there's a lot going on
and he's not alone a lot of North
Americans are suffering from chronic
disease just like Michael's so let's
let's check out gene change happening
and not too long ago finally got some
x-rays of the hips and back to their
bilateral osteoarthritis it occurs and
extra time schedule for teens hip
replaces this bone on bone this is the
grinding of the joint my stability is
scary
I hold on to the wall if I'm at home
I've been told to use a walker
I'm only 61 this is not how you're
supposed to live when you're this old I
have a really hard time believing it and
follow the slant so in this very
carefully crafted and staged piece you
know we see dark dingy settings
lots of medication Al they've got poor
mobility it's the bad news all around
really so let's just keep in the back of
our mind how our individuals are
portrayed in some of these earlier
sections of the film and how they differ
from some of the later sections when our
two individuals have been on a vegan
diet for two weeks
let's take a look those are so amazing I
know from going from the Walker meeting
wheelchair assistance about the airport
to strolling down the street enjoying
the fresh air and sunshine
two weeks it's all it took two weeks
get off all the meds and start to to
feel the inflammation just kind of drain
out of the body where the movement with
much easier just a lot of healing
occurred very very rapidly just by doing
the right thing for your body all right
well done Jane let's take a look at our
friend Michael Valentine's Day I decided
to go visit and give up all the witches
never in my thoughts in a wild million
years but I've heard so much success
from people that aren't vegan and so we
got gave up all animal product
whatsoever I've lost 29 pounds I've been
able to cut my meds than half I've been
able to cut my insulin in half and now
I'm going for the moon I'm going to cut
it all out in the last six weeks we've
just had three grandchildren and my ugly
face is gonna be around and seeing
graduate from high school and college is
going to be here so guys like let's be
honest I'm really happy for these people
they made some dietary changes they're
feeling better this is exactly why
dietitians do what they do
it's exciting to watch these kinds of
transformations however this is classic
testimonial psychology here
we went from a dark dingy room covered
in medications and obviously not feeling
well two beautiful bright scenery lots
of color hair makeup people talking
about grandchildren I mean obviously
you're going to be thinking that that
vegan diet is directly correlated with
some of these outcomes but that's not
necessarily the case so we don't know
with a sample size of two that removing
the meat in their diet had the intended
effect of reducing their chronic disease
was it perhaps something else like a
lifestyle change like them walking or
moving more was it the fact that their
diet beforehand with some eating five
McDonald's cheeseburgers and getting rid
of those and incorporating more fruits
and vegetables of course had that
intended effect
we have no idea and this brings me to
the fact that during the nutrition
research is really really difficult
I mean this is why we need really huge
sample sizes and we need to control for
confounding factors in or
to understand how one thing influences
another thing doing a testimonial with
two people who got on a vegan diet does
not constitute high quality research
okay guys let's sum this film up so I
think that what the health actually does
a pretty good job communicating some of
the environmental and even some of the
health concerns associated with eating
an excess of meat I definitely think we
could all do better to consume less
animal products and incorporates more
plant-based proteins into our diet and I
think veganism can be really healthy
both for our body and our environment
when done right
however forcing this information down
people's throat using fear is just the
wrong way to go about it I mean we are
now facing a rise in a ton of food
fear-based eating disorders things like
orthorexia so this kind of communication
of food information is not benign it's
actually seriously dangerous so
nutrition research is not that simple
guys so don't expect to get it all in a
90-minute food documentary so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give us a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of your thoughts
on what the health did you like it you
hate it let me know subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]